john i feel like i see you every day
because you do that canadian commercial
i think you're an
honorary canadian well i hope so you
know had things gone differently in the
election i might have taken you up on
that but here we are i think we
we've turned the page and uh it's uh
it's a
it's it's it's a pleasure i'll be honest
i know you look great in canadian tuxedo
now uh john
john patrick it's been 12 years and it
is amazing to see this film it's such a
delight to watch uh
as the director what did you think of
the film was it everything you wanted
yeah it actually came out the way that i
intended and more so
because the actors always bring the
unexpected
gifts that actors bring and in this case
i had
you know really the a team
and i could just get out of their way
and let them
do what they do and they they brought a
lot of wonderful
wonderful qualities to it and then i got
to shoot in ireland which is
one of the most beautiful places on
earth yeah
and john you got to hang out with
christopher walken like come on those
scenes together
what was it like to be with such an icon
well it's
he's he's a lovely lovely man and uh he
is
truly uh obviously gifted in so many
ways but
but what's rare about chris is that
and we see it less and less these days
is that he is a unique
personality a unique talent a unique
individual and that's
that oozes from him uh
john patrick tells the story about how
he was so taken with ireland he would
just sit and stare out his window all
day
and look at the cows and then come up
with stories about what the cows were
doing and talking about and plotting
against him and
who does that chris walken does that so
there you go
yeah and and this is a love letter to
ireland i want to visit ireland i've
never been and
that's what makes it so spectacular to
watch this film i need to know if either
of you have the
i guess the irish accent to say a love
letter to ireland can one of you try it
with an irish brogue yes
but it's a love letter to ireland oh i
can't do any better than that
come on john well it's a wee love letter
to ireland
pretty good i like it you know and also
when you're on the plane
i miss traveling i think all of us
really do miss just being out there and
just exploring the world but uh john it
got me thinking about top gun too
how was it i need to know that
experience with tom cruise was it
everything you expected
yeah it is and i think once people see
it they'll realize it's
it's a really wonderful combination it's
a perfect balance of
you know nostalgia for the original and
yet it takes the story to another place
that's very exciting
at the the the visuals in the film are
unreal
uh it's everything a big giant hollywood
movie should be i hope by that by
by springtime summertime where we're
able to go to theaters again
because it needs to be seen big and loud
and uh i hope people get a chance to do
that
i love that and with the holidays just
around the corner and this movie's about
family are you
expected to i mean i know it's gonna be
different this year but are you
expecting to
have some plans this time around well
yeah you know yeah hopefully
hopefully we'll both uh you know be able
to to see family or at least be
surrounded by
by warmth i mean i think that's really
what we're all looking for at this point
any warmth yeah john patrick thank you
so much to both of you it's a
wonderful film and i i hope i i can't
wait for everyone to watch it so we
really appreciate it thank you
thank you happy holidays bye
you